how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today is the official launch day of
Disney plus and the official launch day
of the mandalorian season 1 episode 1 a
lot of things happened in this episode
and you may have some questions but
don't worry we're going to break it all
down I will be covering each episode of
the mandalorian doing breakdowns and
talking about ending explanations as
well so if you'd like to stay up to date
on everything relating to the
mandalorian be sure to subscribe to my
channel I'm also giving away an Xbox one
or ps4 all the up to do to enter is
subscribe but the notifications turned
on like this video and comment down
below so we are finally introduced to
the mandalorian so remember this takes
place after the fall of the Empire so
right now the part of the galaxy that
their end is kind of a lawless state so
the Mandalorian starts off in a cantina
where these two thugs are picking on
this one guy and then the Mandalorian
enters the thugs then start to mess with
the bounty hunter the Mandalorian and of
course that does not go well he takes
out all of the thugs in a very awesome
scene but then he goes over to the guy
that they were picking on the guy thinks
that the Mandalorian just wants some
credits for saving his life but of
course he's actually a bounty hunter and
he is the bounty so he ends up taking
the bounty back to his ship and there's
some really cool scenes that are
involved here his ship is on the ice and
there's a giant sea monster that breaks
through and he bites the ship keeping it
from lifting off and then the
Mandalorian shocks him with his weapon
then of course the bounty tries to
escape and then the Mandalorian puts him
in frozen Carbonite which is obviously a
huge flashback to episode 5 with Han
Solo so then he ultimately makes it back
to grief karda who was Carl Weathers his
character and he collects his bounty and
he wants more bounties from him but he
basically gives him some really low
bounties he says that the prize for the
bounties isn't even enough to get fuel
so he ends up offering him another
bounty but there's a catch there's no
puck that tells you who the bounty is
there's no tracking number there's
nothing he tells him that he has to go
meet the person that has put out the
bounty face to face so the Mandalorian
accepts the bounty and he ends up making
his way to the character known as the
client when he gets to the clients
location he has a chip that is scanned
by a droid the same one that was in
Return of the Jedi he makes his way into
the room where the client is along with
four stormtroopers the stormtroopers are
very beat up and they're very dirty
because remember there is no more empire
however the client is wearing an
imperial insignia
implying that he may have been someone
of high rank in the Imperial Army before
it got destroyed and the stormtroopers
that are with him were most likely men
that served him that just followed him
along after we don't find out the name
of the client it's probably going to be
revealed later on I wouldn't be
surprised if he is an extremely
important character that is connected to
somebody from the old Star Wars series
we are then introduced to dr. Pershing
he ends up giving the Mandalorian the
tracker fob for the bounty and then we
hear an argument between him and the
client dr. Pershing says that the bounty
needs to be returned alive but then the
client says that you can bring the asset
back dead however the bounty will be
much less so the Mandalorian is giving
the tracking fob and that's pretty much
all he gets for this bounty besides the
fact that the age of the asset is 50 now
the payout for this bounty is
Mandalorian steel bhaskar now buscar'
steel is an extremely rare and durable
steel only found on the planet Mandalore
and it's moon the client says that he
believes that buscar' should be long
with its people the Mandalorians we go
on to learn from the woman in the armory
that Mandalorian steel was stolen from
the Mandalorians during the purge now
they do not clarify what the purge is
but there is a chance that they could be
referring to the Jedi purge so the
blacksmith melts down the metal and
forges a shoulder plate for him and as
she's forging this shoulder plate the
Mandalorian starts to get flashbacks and
we find out that the Mandalorian was
actually a foundling we see flashbacks
of the Clone Wars we can see super
battle droids kind of just destroying
everything in the city and everyone so
we see the Mandalorians parents hide him
and it's safe to assume that since he's
a foundling his parents are dead so we
get a little bit of the Mandalorians
origin story they're also worth noting
that we see the Mandalorian sign above
the room now the sign is a mythos or
mythos Orr's used to be creatures on
Mandalore
however the Mandalorians hunted them
into extinction
so the skull of a mythos sort is now the
symbol of the Mandalorians so the
Mandalorian eventually makes it on his
way after he gets his shoulder piece and
he arrives at a planet where he is
attacked by two blurbs and this is
actually a really cool scene because we
get to see the Mandalorian use his
flamethrower the flamethrower is
something that the Mandalorians would
use against the Jedi because the Jedi
cannot block fire at least not with a
lightsaber
he is saved by their owner who is Nick
Nolte's character I believe is
pronounced squeal and he recognizes that
he is a Mandalorian and wants to help
him after a scene of learning how to
ride a blurred they get to the
destination of where the asset is we
learned that queal is helping the
Mandalorian because he wants these
mercenaries off his planet so the planet
can once again be at peace he leaves him
and right before the Mandalorian is
about to go down he sees a bounty droid
this bounty droid is IG 11 voiced by the
one and only Taika Waititi the director
of thor ragnarok and he also plays korg
of course so IG 11 goes in and requests
the asset obviously they're not having
this so they opened fire on IG 11 and he
just goes to town this was one of the
best scenes in this episode the way the
IG 11 is able to attack the way he
twists and turns was just absolutely
awesome to watch but IG 11 is kind of
throwing off the Mandalorians plan so he
jumps down and tries to talk to him but
ends up getting shot by him now of
course it's revealed that he's a bounty
hunter and the two of them decide to
team up and this is where the best scene
of this episode begins they both start
to take out a lot of guards until
eventually they get to the door that
they need to get through the door
doesn't open and they end up getting
cornered at the door the Mandalorian has
a plan until this massive turret shows
up so he tells IG 11 to go draw the fire
away and when he does he ends up taking
out the gunner of the turret the
Mandalorian then jumps in the turret and
completely destroys everybody definitely
the best scene of this episode so they
eventually get through the door and
after killing one straggler they
eventually find the asset the tracker
has led them to a tiny little pod the
Mandalorian opens it up and IG 11 and
the Mandalorian just stare at it then
the Mandalorian says wait I thought they
said 50 years old as in the asset was
supposed to be 50 years old then IG 11
says species age differently perhaps it
could live many centuries sadly we'll
never know then he points his blaster at
the baby Yoda and then the Mandalorian
shoots him right in the back of the head
now of course the biggest twist of this
episode is that the asset is a baby
Yoda now for those of you who do not
know Yoda species has actually never
been revealed in Star Wars lore however
we do know that the creature on the show
is
going to be referred to as the beam now
obviously seen this young Yoda raises
many questions is this young Yoda
related Toyota and why does the client
want this asset now we do know that
Palpatine is going to be returning in
the rise of Skywalker which means that
he is probably around during this time
and the client since he was wearing an
imperial insignia and had stormtroopers
with him could most likely still be
working for Palpatine so maybe Yoda
species could carry an extreme amount of
midi-chlorians
maybe they view this young Yoda as a
future powerful Jedi and this could
perhaps be why dr. Pershing wants the
asset alive because he would like to
study it perhaps study its blood and see
how many many chlorines it has but the
fact that it could be a future Jedi is
perhaps why the client doesn't care if
it comes back dead or alive if you have
your own theory so let me know down
below and let me know what you thought
about the Mandalorian if you enjoyed the
video please give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
and comment below so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof